hello hey honey how are the kids
everything's great
is she having adolescence and jack-jack
he's in excellent health
i'm cooking okay wow okay
that is freaky
[Music]
see what i did there what's up global
citizens today
we are learning english with pixar
disney's animation
the incredibles 2. you'll learn lots of
business related vocabulary
you can start using right now while
understanding a bit more of the american
lifestyle
but in case you're new here the scenes
we chose have
no spoilers you will watch two scenes
from the movie
learn the vocabulary and then have the
chance to watch it again
without the subtitles with a few quiz
questions because
that's what we do here at learn english
with tv three times a week
we help you understand fast english
without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles
just like hamad who says that our
channel is an effective way to learn
english if you enjoy learning with your
favorite movies and tv series
don't forget to give us a thumbs up and
also check out our disney playlist
where you'll find lessons with seoul up
tangled
and so many great more movies just click
the link in the description below
let's get started with the lesson
we've got resources lobbyists worldwide
connections
and very important insurance insurance
is key
all we need now are the superior
superheroes it needs
you three come on help me make all
supers legal again this sounds great
let's get this going what's my first
assignment that enthusiasm
is golden hold on to it
after being forced to hide their
superheroes identities
the incredibles actually elastigirl is
offered an attractive job opportunity
that would allow the whole family to be
superheroes again
we've got resources lobbyists worldwide
connections
and very important insurance insurance
is key
when they are presented with the job
opportunity there are a few advantages
highlighted
let's look at them the first one is
resources
resources refer to everything valuable
that a company has
such as equipment employees technology
and so on having resources can also
imply that the company has a large
budget
that is enough money to develop a
project or achieve
its goals borstman is his backer
i know
well then you know that he has unlimited
resources and i can't fight a war on
multiple fronts
the second advantage of the job
presented to the incredibles is the
lobbyists
a lobbyist or lobby group is a person or
group
who try to influence politicians or
influential groups to change a law
to benefit that lobby group a well-known
lobby group in the u.s
is the national rifle association
commonly referred
to as the nra the third thing mentioned
in an attempt to convince them
is worldwide connections worldwide is
used to refer to things that exist or
happen across the globe
this means that the company is known and
connected to different parts of the
world
another phrase he could have used to
express the idea of worldwide
connections
is we are part of a global network
just now at a worldwide summit leaders
from more than a hundred of the world's
top countries have agreed to make
superheroes legal again
if you are looking into expanding your
network to feel more confident to speak
english
and connect with people from all around
the globe then i want to tell you
you can do it all at just the touch of a
button
we built the real life app so that you
can connect to
other english learners from around the
world and practice your speaking
while discovering other cultures in a
fun and dynamic way
through short conversations it's like
your virtual passport to the world
in addition to that you can improve your
comprehension
with real-life native conversations by
following a transcription
of our podcast you will understand 100
and never forget the most important
vocabulary so download it now by
clicking the link down in the
description below
or search for the real life english app
in the apple app store
or the google play store i look forward
to seeing you there
we've got resources lobbyists worldwide
connections
and very important insurance insurance
is key
the final argument to convince them to
take the job is
insurance most likely he's referring to
health insurance
that is a plan to cover medical expenses
mr incredible gets excited and says that
insurance is
key if something is key it means that
it's fundamental
or really important the reason why he
says that
is because medical care in the us tends
to be quite expensive and
for being a father of three having
access to this benefit
is extremely important to him insurance
oh yeah check it definitely gonna want
some of that
you don't have insurance why how much is
this gonna cost
i have no idea but x-rays alone could be
a couple hundred dollars well what are
we gonna do
there's not much we can do um
unless unless i use yours
well now wait a second who did i just
put as my in case of emergency person
it's insurance fraud dr johnson
well all right then forget it i will
just go home
come on help me make all supers legal
again
legal is a term used to refer to
anything connected with the law
thus the legal department in a company
is responsible for dealing with all
legal matters
such as contracts forms and so much more
conversely if something is illegal it
means that it is contrary to
or prohibited by the law i also do not
advise you to fill out and file iws2475
form with our legal department on the
second floor
she's an advocate for superheroes it's a
new job
so mom is going out illegally to explain
why she shouldn't be illegal this sounds
great let's get this going did you
notice how he connected the words get
and this let's get this going you can
hear only one t
sound this is a common feature of
connected speech
when one word ends with and the next
word begins with the same consonant
sound
they are connected and you pronounce
that sound a little bit longer
we call this gemination take a look
social life social life
now try it with me i don't have much of
a social life
this site this site
now repeat after me the tickets are
cheaper on this site
[Music]
calm man come man
now try it with me he seems such a calm
man
what's my first assignment that
enthusiasm is golden
hold on to it when mr incredible asks
what's my first assignment he wants to
know what his mission will be
you call an assignment every job or task
a boss or a teacher gives you to do
now go on your new shoot will be
finished before your next assignment
you know i'm retired from hero work that
enthusiasm is golden
what does he mean by that enthusiasm is
golden
a having enthusiasm means earning more
money
b having enthusiasm is appreciated and
valued by the company
c having enthusiasm will bring more
profits to the company
[Music]
if you chose b then you are correct
literally golden refers to anything that
is made of
gold however if you say that something
is golden
it means that it is valuable important
or advantageous
[Music]
just right
you're so golden hold on to it
here mr deva asks him to hold on to his
enthusiasm
this means that he wants him to continue
being enthusiastic
about the job he's offering if you ask
someone to hold on to something
you want them to keep doing what they
are doing because it's important or
useful
[Music]
but for our first move well elastigirl
is our best play
better than me
i mean she's good she's a really a
credit tour
but uh you know you know
with great respect let's not test the
whole insurance will pay for everything
idea on the first go round okay right
wait a minute
you're saying what i'm messy well evelyn
did a cost-benefit analysis comparing
all your last five years of crime
fighting before going underground
and elastigirl's numbers are
self-explanatory well it's not a fair
comparison
heavyweight problems need heavyweight
solutions of course
we're going to solve all kinds of
problems together
after the perfect launch with elastigirl
so what do you say
[Music]
but for our first move well elastigirl
is our best play
better than me
a move in the business context is a
strategic action towards an objective
for example our next move is to invest
in
inbound marketing now what's the
difference between better and best
we use better when comparing two things
for example
coffee is better than tea or i have a
better idea
why don't we ask the team which bonus
they prefer
best on the other hand is used when one
option stands out from all the others
for example brazilian coffee is the best
in the world
or do you know what's best to implement
a work from home policy until the
pandemic is over
better and best are respectively the
comparative and superlative forms of
goods
note they are irregular check out
ethan's explanation of regular
comparatives and superlatives
normally comparative adjectives appear
as one of these two
options for short adjectives adjective
plus er example cooler
faster smarter for long adjectives
more plus adjective example more
intelligent
more creative more fascinating
superlatives
normally appear as one of these two
options for short adjectives
adjective plus est example coolest
fastest smartest
so how exactly are you planning to stop
this weather
oh i am gonna talk to my sister yeah
i bet she's the nicest gentlest
warmest person ever for long adjectives
most plus adjective example most
intelligent
most creative most fascinating
i mean she's good she's really a credit
creditor
but uh you know you know
to give someone credit means to
recognize their work
and show they deserve being praised now
did you notice how surprised mr
incredible was in this scene
and because of that it was difficult for
him to find the right words to say
while he was trying to find them he said
i mean
really you know this is a resource of
fluent speakers called
discourse markers check out how andrea
explains and exemplifies this
you need to actively work on specific
things in order to improve
your level so for example i've just been
working on a lesson
with discourse markers and these are a
really important aspect of vocabulary
because
when you can recognize them you can then
actually if you understand that it's a
discourse marker which is basically just
like a
filler and i actually noticed from
starting to work on the podcast and
recording the podcast just how much i
used them
so it really allowed me to realize how
much i use discourse markers
can you give a couple examples yeah so
there's one
so so it's just kind of linking my ideas
together
you don't really need to know the
meaning of it or really think about oh
so she's saying so what does that mean
and then there's other ones like i mean
we use i mean a lot at the start of
sentences as well
but it's just to kind of kick off the
sentence you don't really need to think
about those words so if you're
identifying
those if you've actually worked on this
you can identify them and not spend so
much time
translating them or thinking about them
and then when when you have a really
good grip
of them you can even start using them
yourself and what they're going to do
is buy you thinking time in those
moments where you're maybe having a
conversation
and you're not quite sure what to say
next
you can if it's more natural to you you
can use discourse markers as a way
to think about what to say next with
great respect
let's not test the whole insurance will
pay for everything idea on the first
go-round okay
with great respect is a polite way of
disagreeing with what someone said
it's common to also hear with all due
respect
with the same meaning i know the chief
of police there won't be a problem
with all due respect if you alone had
handled the underminer things would have
been different
[Music]
go round in this context is when you do
something
or when you try to do something mr deva
says he doesn't want mr incredible
destroying
everything around him on their first
attempt at the mission of making
superheroes
legal again well evelyn did a
cost-benefit analysis comparing all your
last five years of crime fighting before
going underground
and elastigirl's numbers are
self-explanatory cost-benefit analysis
or cba is something done by companies to
evaluate if a project is worth pursuing
they measure if the benefits will
compensate for all the financial costs
involved in taking action if you steal
my watch
by midnight i will do your paperwork for
a week but if you fail you will give me
five weeks of overtime for free
correct i'm doing a cost benefit
analysis in my head
the benefits outweigh the costs
underground literally means below the
surface
it's even the name given to the railroad
system the subway
in the uk however here underground
refers to a secret
illegal activity careful not to confuse
it with going undercover
which means using a false appearance to
obtain information for the police or
government he was heartbroken when you
were all forced to go underground
father believed the world would be more
dangerous without you
assignments officers grizzoni fangmai
delgato
tundratown swat snarloff higgins
wolford undercover pops
wild parking duty
dismissed and elastigirl's numbers are
self-explanatory
if something is self-explanatory it
means that it is obvious and doesn't
need
extra explanation or illustration
richard can you stop i can explain
okay it's pretty self-explanatory monica
you voted to fire me
well it's not a fair comparison
heavyweight problems need heavyweight
solutions
of course if something is heavyweight it
means that it's important
so mr incredible does a wordplay with
heavyweight here
when he shows that he is the one that
should do the job
he means that important problems need
heavy weight solutions
the joke is that heavy weight is also
something or
someone that is above the average weight
that is
someone who is bigger or fatter than the
others
additionally it also refers to the
strongest
and biggest people particularly in a
boxing match
mr incredible no doubt considers himself
the strongest
which is why he volunteers himself to
fix the heavyweight problem
of course we're going to solve all kinds
of problems together
after the perfect launch with elastigirl
so what do you say launching is the
process
of introducing a new product into the
market for customers to buy
to launch our magnificent new hover tray
so what do you say in connected speech
consonant and vowel sounds change all
the time in order to make the speech
that is the muscle and voice work easier
for the body
in this sentence the t in what changes
to become similar to the d
sound in do that's why there's a role of
the tongue when you hear
what do you say let's try it out what do
you say
you might hear this referred to as the
flap t sound in american english
i hope you enjoyed learning with the
incredibles 2 today
and before you watch the scenes without
subtitles and answer a few quiz
questions
i want to tell you that i have a bonus
lesson for you over on our instagram
so run over there at reallife.english
because i prepared a lesson with the
incredibles family
having just another family moment and
did you know that you can learn english
every day with us
that's right every day we have different
lessons on all of our channels
podcasts and instagram make sure you
follow us on instagram
reallife.english to be informed of the
lessons
we publish every day oh yeah
[Music]
we've got resources lobbyists worldwide
connections
and very important insurance insurance
is key
what is the meaning of key in this
context
a essential b required
c trivial
[Music]
all we need now are the super
superheroes it needs
you three come on help me make all
supers legal again but this sounds great
let's get this going what's my first
assignment that enthusiasm is
golden hold on to it but for our first
move well elastigirl is our best play
better than
me i mean she's good she's
really a credit to her but uh you know
you know with great respect let's not
test the whole
insurance will pay for everything idea
on the first go round okay
all right wait a minute you're saying
what i'm
messy well evelyn did a cost-benefit
analysis comparing all your last five
years of crime fighting before going
underground
if something happens underground it
means that a
it's done under the ground b it's done
illegally
see it's done by a police officer
and elastigirl's numbers are
self-explanatory well it's not a fair
comparison
heavyweight problems need heavyweight
solutions of course
we're going to solve all kinds of
problems together
after the perfect launch with elastigirl
in which sentence below does the word
launch mean introduce a new product into
the market
a the police have launched an
investigation into his activities
b the launch was successful and we've
grown 20
of our revenue already see nasa is
planning to launch a telescope mission
in december
[Music]
this is our new house okay easy tiger
is being loaned to us this is homey
look at this place deborah bought it
from an eccentric billionaire who liked
to come and go
without being seen so the house has
multiple hidden exits
good thing we won't stand out we don't
want to attract any unnecessary
[Music]
do you want to understand your favorite
disney movies well this lesson is based
on the themes
and characters of one of pixar's best
movies wally
so first andrea and i will introduce you
to the story of the movie
by talking about the setting main
character and theme
then as we do that you'll learn some
vocabulary related to the story of the
movie
and then we will have a chat about this
beautiful movie
involving this cute little robot named
wally